is my great pleasure to introduce
Allison Luka see today's student speaker
who was selected to represent your class
Allison's graduating today with a
Bachelor of architecture she also
received both the Carnegie Mellon
presidential merit scholarship and the
Bernard Maybeck scholarship for academic
excellence and leadership Allison Lucas
e Thank You president Cohen and a
special thank you to my family for
always believing in me welcome family
friends faculty staff guests of the
University and class of 2009 this is our
time today I would like to talk about
the buzzword of the past year change
climate change economic change cultural
change change in the aesthetics of our
campus it is nearly impossible to take a
breath without the word change thanks to
walking to the sky and the gates hillman
complex and we are all the better for it
bruce barton author of personal success
guides in the roaring 20s famously said
when you are through changing you are
through we may be through with many
things late nights painting the fence
building booth for carnival and loop
adventures to the south side but
certainly we are not through with change
especially at Carnegie Mellon where we
are the catalyst for change looking back
at photos the first ever to be posted on
Facebook we can all laugh at how young
we looked and in the not so distant
future we will look back at today's
photo albums and laugh about how we
brought in the largest crowd Gessling
state
has ever seen and how much we have
changed I knew Carnegie Mellon was the
right place for me after just minutes of
having unpacked the last of my clothes
hangers and computer cables a new
neighbor of mine in Forbes house came
bounding into my room and without
hesitation began to gush about how
thrilled she was to be in Pittsburgh to
her being at Carnegie Mellon was like
the Steelers winning the Super Bowl
twice and for years no less needless to
say my family thought she was crazy I
knew she was a sign of just how great
the next few years promised to be and my
intuition was proved right she is just
one of the many people I have come to
know and love because you have so much
passion and dedication for what we do at
Carnegie Mellon there are many reasons
why each of us is at once thrilled and
devastated to be leaving this campus
where else do people celebrate four days
of carnival with a sweepstakes race
pushing buggies through Schenley Park
where else will you ever be given the
opportunity to ride brightly
spray-painted bikes from class to class
for free where else would the entire
Greek community come together to put on
Broadway quality performances in memory
of Randy Pausch author of the last
lecture where else can you listen two
melodies drifting out of cfa and witness
Moe Bock's crawling on the lawn only at
Carnegie Mellon in 1900 Andrew Carnegie
proclaimed my heart is in the work today
we talk about pioneering solutions for
the world yesterday each of us was one
of 10,000 students today we represent a
liver of the seventy thousand alumni
proud to bear the names of Andrew
Carnegie and Andrew Mellon the first
citizens of Athens once said to their
Athenian public what we leave behind is
not what is engraved in stone monuments
but what is woven into the lives of
others each one of us has influenced
more people than we now know our friends
surrounding us our families in the
stands our professors and people who
have yet to step foot in these hallowed
halls we are who we are because of
Carnegie Mellon a little piece of tartan
plaid forever stitched in our hearts and
work once upon a time we arrived in
Pittsburgh for orientation unpacked
filed out to this field and sat on the
laps of strangers born in the same month
somewhere and all of this we went from
being roommates two best friends I am
sports players to significant others
freshman floor mates to sorority sisters
a sampling of highly intelligent and
genuinely passionate people from around
the world who now sure profound and
lasting bond in these last few weeks
replete with our last reading days and
hunt and all of the events of senior
week filled with bittersweet goodbyes
and reminiscing we have hit the rewind
button we're squeezing years of memories
into the uhaul has only just begun
freshman year the School of Architecture
made the front page of the Tartan we
hung a sign in a window of a margaret
morrison studio late one night that read
help sleep needed
little did we know as young naive
freshman that sleep is never needed at
Carnegie Mellon continuously ranked in
Princeton reviews top 10 students never
stop studying my fellow graduates here
and now is our reward as you r assess
out of the stadium today I challenge
each of us every single person listening
to these words to be the change you wish
to see in the world Gandhi said it best
we must embrace change if we are to be
the leaders thinkers and innovators of
the future the only way to conclude our
final chapter at CMU is to end it the
way it began we are the class of 2009
and please join me because we want a
standing ovation
you